senior political analyst Brit Hume joins
us again tonight can evening Britain
your thoughts on the the Democrat memo
all the fallout from it this weekend
well I I've read both these memos
carefully and the Republican memo
basically asserts that the FBI and
Justice Department made improper use of
this so-called dossier which is a
collection of you know to some extent
unverified to considerable extent
unverified material a lot of it
salacious as you heard Katherine report
quoting Comey in acquiring a warrant to
spy on a man Carter page who had been
advising the Trump campaign and they
alleged two things the Republicans did
one was that they made heavy use of this
dossier which was which was an improper
basis for a warrant and secondly that
they failed to inform the court of the
extent to which this was a partisan
document basically paid for by the
Democratic Party in the Clinton campaign
the Democratic memo attempts to rebut
that but it doesn't really do that it
says for example that there was a lot of
other verify whether solid material used
as the basis for this warrant but if
that were true then why why bring the
dossier into it at all if they had
plenty of other basis for the warrant
and the second thing that the Democrats
argue of course is that that the court
was properly informed of the extent to
which this is a partisan document well I
have read the quote in the repentant
Democrats memo and it is a met it is a
masterpiece of circumlocution ending up
being only the vaguest attribution of
this document to to to the to politics
and it certainly doesn't tell the judge
that this was something paid for by the
Clinton campaign in the Democratic Party
so those are kind of the central
allegations that we're dealing with here
and I don't think they're sufficiently
or effectively rebutted by the
Democratic memo yeah I saw some of your
comments over the weekend on Twitter
about it Andrew McCarthy had a pretty
detailed piece point by point about some
of this
in National Review one of the things
that's interesting is to listen to the
Democrats breath who had a real problem
prior to the Nunez
GOP memo coming out weren't warning
about a threat to national security
and yet this memo is is redacted in
parts pretty heavily because sources and
methods are in this memo that's right
there was a Democrats remember this
bread going back to them to them to the
time when the when the Republican memo
was first about to emerge and the
Democrats had whomped up their memo
after the Republicans had written theirs
as a rebuttal and the Democrats on that
committee were prepared to have both
memos unchanged released right away and
that didn't happen the Republican memo
was put through a process the Democratic
memo went through the same process later
the Republican memo was found to have
very little if anything in it that
revealed sources and methods and we saw
when it came out that there were no
redactions the Democratic memo comes
along the Democrats were prepared to
release without without any further
review and it's absolutely laced with
redactions made it at the suggestion of
the FBI and the Justice Department and
the intelligence community to protect
sources and methods so it's a peculiar
thing to the Democrats have been
charging all along when they produce
this memo that appears to have been
appears to have had an array of
disclosures of classified information
relating the sources and methods
interesting we'll see where it all goes
Britt as always thank you you bet